des personnes par centaines se sont
réunis devant la mairie de poissy ce
lundi 19 octobre après l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit la municipalité a invité
les habitants au recueillement
nous souhaitions rendre hommage à samuel
pâtit mais également à l'ensemble du
corps enseignant qui chaque jour
construit n'aurait certes il y avait eu
ce drame mais qui est important pour
nous de dire aux uns et aux autres que
nous étions ensemble en fraternité
de nombreux enseignants et
professionnels de l'éducation étaient
présents dans la foule
je suis directrice d'école sur la ville
et ça me paraissait important de rendre
hommage à un collègue qui a été
lâchement assassinés
on est horrifiée parce que quelqu'un qui
fait un métier très noble certains
diront le plus beau métier du monde
il a été exécuté dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
donc c'est incompréhensible et voilà
c'est pour lui dire et dire à sa famille
on est là il est parti certes mais il
raisonne au coeur à versailles une
minute de silence a été observée bougies
et fleurs ont été déposées sur les
marches de l'hôtel de ville les
habitants sont venus soutenir le corps
enseignant pour soutenir la laïcité le
droit d'expression le droit à la parole
de droit à nos jeunes de vivre de
pouvoir exprimer de pouvoir être libre
aux femmes aux jeunes femmes aux hommes
au jeune homme
et puis surtout la liberté d'expression
de droit aux professeurs de faire leur
travail correctement sans ambiguïté sans
sens sans être offensé comme là c'est la
mairie qui est à l'origine de ce
rassemblement
il était important pour la municipalité
de témoigner de sa solidarité
pour nous c'est vraiment un beau
témoignage la solidarité des gens face à
ces crimes souvent atroce
et puis aussi la solidarité autour du
corps professoral autour des enseignants
parce qu'à travers sa mère pattie c'est
aussi tous les enseignants qui sont
honorés tous ceux qui ont le courage
effectivement de rappeler les valeurs de
notre pays
ces deux rassemblements ont eu lieu
avant le grand hommage national prévu
mercredi 21 octobre à la sorbonne